few games use live-action cutscenes as
emphatically as quantum break and for
all intents and purposes it's one of the
games defining elements between each of
its five gameplay based chapters you
have the opportunity to watch roughly 20
minute long episodes which are entirely
optional but designed to offer a wealth
of insight into the antagonist state of
mind otherwise quantum break focuses on
Jack Joyce the time-bending lead
character played by shawn ashmore better
known as Iceman from the x-men films
Ashmore is one of a few well-known
actors featured in quantum break and
each member's professional acting chops
are put to good use of course quantum
break is intended to be played rather
than merely watched but even if you skip
its optional episodes the best aspects
of its gameplay are suppressed by
frequent bouts of mundane indie combat
is the unequivocal star of the show here
driven by time-based super powers at
your disposal at the start of the game
you're imbued with the ability to
manipulate time which allows you to slow
down combat speed up Jack's movement
create shields that freeze bullets upon
impact or cast time blast bombs near
unsuspecting enemies and it doesn't take
long to develop a flow to understand how
to link one ability to the next by
managing each moves cooldown timer you
can thrust yourself into danger to
establish line-of-sight on an enemy and
protect yourself for the shield while
you open fire when your defenses run out
you can quickly zip into cover and cast
a time blast or continue to use your
firearms while your abilities refresh
there's no one right way to fight and
there's great enjoyment to be found in
experimenting with your abilities
not to mention witnessing the
environment react to your powers as the
scene shifts cracks and glitches out
around you quantum break is a great
looking game with some truly impressive
character models that bring its actors
to life and the time based special
effects are a constant source of
amazement there's also an incredible
amount of real-time destruction on
display which not only looks great but
also keeps you moving during combat as
enemies regularly destroy your hiding
spots quantum break shooting mechanics
however are slightly less impressive
there are times when your enemies
introduce devices that disrupt your
superhuman abilities and you have no
choice but to resort to your firearms
now we would be unfair to compare simple
shooting to manipulating time but it is
reasonable to hold quantum break to
modern third-person shooting standards
you spend a lot of time in cover during
combat and while it's possible to blind
fire your time blast ability you can't
use your guns with the same amount of
freedom you don't have the option to
shoot while crouched you have to stand
up and expose yourself to other enemies
and usually take damage unless you have
enough energy to cast a time shield
around yourself of course this is an
option that shouldn't be needed we
already have suitable cover both aiming
and movement feel loose and cumbersome
making the aim-assist feature the only
reliable way to consistently pick off
enemies when you're not engaged in
combat you're probably exploring
environments for clues and story tidbits
or traversing obstacles during
ill-conceived platforming challenges
again movement is so loose in quantum
break and the combats so exciting that
it's frustrating when you're forced to
slow down awkwardly scale objects and
leap around
sadly quantum breaks gameplay is
essentially divided equally between
combat and hapless environmental
traversal given that the entire campaign
can be completed in less than 10 hours
live action episodes included the
distribution of activities feels that
much more disappointing prior to the TV
show like episodes you get to make
decisions for your nemesis Paul serene
which have an impact on some events in
the show and in the game the effect of
most decisions are noticeable but not
truly consequential in part because the
game's cliched potentially story
spoiling opening dulls your sense of
wonder from the get-go far worse however
is the end result quantum break only has
one ending realizing this your choices
ultimately feel trivial and not worth
reconsidering you're encouraged to
replay the game but by the time you
reach the credits it's unlikely you'll
feel motivated to do so so by the end
you know the most important parts of the
story and you understand that replaying
it to witness alternative events in the
middle would require you to retread
well-worn
sometimes boring territory getting to
the end of quantum break can be an
interesting ride at times but no matter
how impressive the combat is no matter
how great the game looks there's no
getting around the fact that it's driven
by a story with limited appeal and
hindered by disappointing design
decisions